the environment would definitely what we
want and climate you know what we're
doing to the climate is one and this
that would definitely be one of the
salient the salient issues of our time
another i think that is salient is this
this struggle between the the forces of
purple deliberate ignorance and the
forces of of thinking and intellect and
research and so on and so forth I mean
it is shameful or what to see some
candidates for president signed Walder
you know I'm really not so sure about
evolution they should be ashamed of
themselves and their mothers I me not
their mothers should be ashamed of them
I mean it's just it's it's just shocking
and to see people pandering to ignorance
for short-term gain whether it's about
climate or about other things is it it
is to me shame is to me absolutely
shameful it's not just a u.s. problem in
it and it makes my blood boil and and I
think that may be related to that other
issue that i mentioned which is the very
skewed distribution of wealth because if
i can see a five-year opportunity to
make so damn much money that it just
doesn't matter then then it just doesn't
matter then do I become does that
opportunity allow me to become a
sociopath in ways that that that I
wouldn't become if the opportunity we're
not quite so so huge
you